sam knows people can't always understand
his struggles he has the george syndrome
a condition that causes pain and fatigue
not always in a wheelchair he's
constantly questioned about his
disability
when i was younger
and like you now you
and
i
[Music]
went out like
i mean
experiences like those have fueled a
campaign to see the blue badge changed
to represent non-visible disabilities
too the idea for this for this campaign
is one
that sam i think feels quite
passionately about
um
just to make sure that people
really acknowledge that disabilities you
don't have to be in a wheelchair you can
be completely able-bodied but still have
something that impacts on your life and
makes things potentially a little bit
more difficult
charities in the uk say one in five
people have a disability and that 80
percent of those are non-visible sam's
campaign isn't just about changing a
sign the way people are treated when
using facilities they're entitled to
like this parking bay
the sunflower foundation has existed
since 2016. it helps organizations
identify acknowledge and support people
with hidden disabilities
they're also in support of a review of
an icon they feel is outdated the
wheelchair symbol for disabilities
really doesn't represent the disabled
community only seven percent of um
disabled people use use a wheelchair so
it's 93 of people that don't don't use a
work don't use a wheelchair so um it's
really out of sync
with the with with the disabled
community
that community includes people who are
constantly second guessing themselves in
public charlotte lee has fibromyalgia a
condition that causes extreme pain and
fatigue for example if i'm in a queue
and i ask if i can go to the front of
the queue so that i don't have to stand
then you know understandably people get
very cross and frustrated especially
when it's a long queue or if i'm on
public transport and i asked to take a
priority seat that can get very messy
because obviously people look at me and
think she's fine why should i give up my
seat
and you know it's difficult it's very
tough
throw it out that way sam hopes that by
pushing for change he'll be helping more
than himself but a community who don't
always feel seen it would make me feel
wow
sky news